it feels like there was massive chaos
last year uh for anyone who was paying
attention to the podcast you and i
recorded in person in march of 2020 uh
and you pretty much nailed it you i was
that was quite a famous podcast i think
yes and a lot of people were like oh
raul's just being a doomsdayer you know
he's just calling uh the market's gonna
turn over this is gonna be bad and then
like within a week and a half everyone
thought the market was going to zero
right i mean it just got real bad real
fast we obviously had the government
step in we had the interest rate
manipulation we had all the monetary and
fiscal stimulus uh and now we get all
the way up until today how do you
evaluate where we are from a macro
standpoint at the current moment
so i think it's interesting i always
follow narratives and the narrative
right now is
very much on this inflation ongoing
growth
how the fed going to raise rates they
have to taper soon but the work that
i've been doing suggests that
the likelihood is the economy the global
economy slows down
pretty significantly uh into next year
and again we might see more stimulus
and more fiscal stimulus coming as well
so
i look at it very differently to what
most people are seeing but on the
horizon because of like the fiscal cliff
we've got like three and a half percent
of gdp coming off from the fiscal cliff
we've got all of the spending brought
forward that everybody including me did
up their houses over the over the
previous year
um we've also got the fact that oil
prices have gone up that hits household
expenditure um prices in general hit
household expenditure you see these
weird old things like the michigan
university of michigan surveys about
cars houses and durable goods because
the prices all went up basically they've
gone to all-time lows in terms of
affordability so people are stepping
back we're seeing in the housing market
we're seeing all over the place so these
higher prices are kind of a cure for
higher prices
as is often the case and i think that
that's going to lead to much slower
growth than we expect and again as i
said more stimulus and so when we get
slower growth and more stimulus does
that continue to drive the prices higher
and higher and it's almost like a
negative feedback loop because as the
prices go higher growth slows and more
become more and more dependent on that
kind of that external
stimulus
i'm not sure that prices go higher um
that's a supply-driven issue that i
think eventually disappears
assets go higher
and you know that in itself has been a
problem something you know i've
discussed because if you can't buy a
house because you're 32 years old and
your income doesn't go up because
nobody's income is really going up um
then you're kind of getting screwed you
know and that's one of the whole
premises behind you know why i got very
very interested in in bitcoin early on
was seeing this play through and i think
it's just going to continue i think
there's so much debt in the system
there's so much leverage i think the
world is now four hundred and four
hundred percent of gdp in debt
that governments have now realized in
the central banks that they can't let
the collateral go bust i the asset side
of the balance sheet is not allowed to
fall in price
um because if not you get a big margin
call on the economy
so it seems to be that debasement of
currency to drive assets higher
optically
is the only answer they've got now
there's almost no way around it unless
they can generate growth that is
reasonably is higher than previous trend
for a longer period of time and with
this aging population all of this
indebtedness globalization technology
the chances of doing that are low
so one of the things that we spent a lot
of time talking about is if you look at
like a chipotle let's use them as a
proxy for uh kind of hourly wages they
raised wages three to four percent they
then passed that through to menu prices
up three to four percent but if you look
at somebody like i think it was
blackrock they increased the uh
firm wide salaries eight percent it's
almost double and so you almost get this
like bifurcation you get kind of
white-collar workers where they really
understand inflation et cetera much
higher increase but at least they both
increased right so so there is some uh
negating of the levels of inflation uh
when you start to think about the
everyday person whether they are a
white-collar worker uh or they work an
hourly job uh or maybe they're coming
off of unemployment and just now kind of
coming back into the workforce what is
likely to be
kind of their experience if we continue
to see asset prices go up
wages don't necessarily go up nearly as
much and the government steps in is this
in the form of just more kind of
unemployment boost and direct stimulus
checks and we eventually move towards
like a ubi world or is there something
else that you think uh this could take
the form of i don't know and i don't
think anybody's figured it out but the
problem is as you as you're saying it's
right wages don't go up enough the other
thing that's missing from that wage
construct is the fact that all the
boomers are retiring in record numbers
so that's offsetting the amount of total
demand in the economy because a bunch of
people go on no salary apart from on
their savings they didn't really save
that much and then a few others get wage
rises but if you look at the debasement
of the fiat currencies overall that's
going somewhere around 13 15 a year so
that's driving up asset prices
at a minimum of 15 percent a year so
even if your wages go up four you're the
chipotle worker well suddenly you still
can't afford as much of the s p and you
still can't afford um as much you know a
house and all of the same things so
you're still getting net poorer so what
is an asset that's the important thing
for people to understand here an asset
is basically deferred expenditure so you
stick savings into something that you
hope goes up enough in price to offset
inflation and other things and then
eventually you get to spend it by
selling that asset now whether that's
gold or whether it's a house
particularly if it's a second home that
you're trying to rent out or do that
kind of stuff
so
those assets which are your future
wealth are becoming harder to buy so you
can buy less of them
so you are net getting poorer and i
don't know how you're going to solve
that equation i think the next bet is
that fiscal stimulus will do it
but i don't think that's going to be the
case because the chipotle worker is
going to be laid off by robots and as
simple as that we're seeing in
mcdonald's we're seeing in many places
so between artificial intelligence and
robotics you're going to be competing
um for salary
with with somebody who gets
exponentially cheaper in price because
computing power gets exponentially
cheaper
so it's a it's a really really difficult
situation so i think they're going to
continue with the same path for the time
being
by the time the next recession comes um
then i think that's a full roller roll
out of ubi because there's no way around
it
i don't see how you rescue this
situation by doing the same thing again
and again we know the outcome we've seen
it since 2008
and nothing's going to change with that